all right now since you guys are you 12
now because you couldn't I can't do this
to you know students I'm going to pose
you a fun little question that um well I
won't I went to you the whole secret to
it but let me see if you can try and
work it out let's play a game it's it's
me this is all of you guys okay and it's
a it's a coin flipping game okay so
suppose the game is whoever's the first
to flip a tail because you can see I'm
clearly into tails right whoever's the
first to flip a tail
wins the game okay I go first because I
have the Quinn and I say so right I go
first if I don't if I get a tail I win
if I don't get a tail mm-hmm
like I didn't right that means you get
to have a go and you get to flip wow
that was a terrible thing that's okay
where'd you get him okay so you didn't
get a tail right bad luck and now it's
my going get it going in okay and then
we keep going right and here's my
question for you I started right so
you'd probably assume that I'm more
likely to win but the question is how
much more likely to am I to win number
one and number two hockey prove it
because actually working out how much
more likely I am to me it's actually
quite easy but showing it little
trickier okay
is it really there you have a go if you
figure out an answer
um call me over and I'll have a look and
I spoil this okay so I'm looking for two
things assume it's actually a fair coin
this time number one how much more
likely am I to win number two why okay
okay I'm gonna try and explain all of me
I sort of three in the deep end a little
bit because it's kind of like you sort
of know what the answer is it's twice as
likely by the way I'm twice more likely
to win some twice is or something anyway
uh but how do you show it that is the
hard part
okay and especially because this is a
probability tree that never ends it's
because you don't know how many turns
it's going to take for someone to win
right we couldn't clean this for ages if
we get lots and lots of it okay so
here's the way that I would draw the
diagram and prove it
the first thing is that occurs is that
there's two right namely a tail or a
head okay but you also need to indicate
somewhere in your diagram that this is
me and not you
right so I'm just going to put down here
this is my turn okay so I don't need to
put any probabilities on these just yet
because they're equal but I'm gonna do
it anywhere you'll see why under second
this is a half this is a huff okay know
what happens if I get the tail first go
it's game over
I've already won okay so this doesn't go
anywhere it finishes it ends but if I
get a head in case going so there are
more branches now just like me you've
got two possibilities here you are you
can get a head or a tail right now the
probability is still the same the reason
why I'm writing on there so that the
product rule is a little more obvious
right because what's your chance of
winning it's not the same as mine right
your chance of winning is not a half
it's 1/2 times 1/2 because these events
must happen together simultaneously
right so my first chance of winning at
that point is 1/2 1 right but then yours
is a quarter of a second go now
you need to keep on going because you
can see I haven't got all of the events
yet right
although I have the entire sample space
with all my possible minutes add up to 1
because that's the sum of everything
right so I've only got 3 quarters so the
25% change there no one's won at this
right so it continues now if I do I'll
get you more I think this next time I
have a probability of 1/8 right it's a
half again and then the next time you
guys will have a probability of 1/16
okay now intuition tells you every time
right we have that respective turns mine
is twice as likely as yours and you can
keep the pattern going but how do you
show it well the probability of me
winning right okay is all of those
together right you have to get all of
them because that's why I have to keep
going forever in order to get my sample
space adding up to 1 right so therefore
it's 1/2 plus 1/8 plus plus and so on
forever it's really important ok now
that that's something you know right
this is a series okay this is a series
where that's equal to SMN where I shot
you right where what kind of series is
it geometric right where my first term
is 1/2 and my ratio is what is my ratio
it's 1/4 right so therefore this is
equal to because that ratio is less than
1 it's it's got a limiting son so it's a
on 1 minus R all right sir 1/2 this aim
on 1 minus 1/4 okay so I've got 1/2
divided by 3/4 so when you flip
everything upside down
to overthrew okay and naturally the
probability of you winning is the
complement of that right so it's 1 minus
me so that's why it's 1/3 hence places
like okay so it's kind of neat because
it's it's simple stuff but it's an
application of something which you don't
usually connect to probability okay